-The Supreme Court dealt
President Trump
yet another major
legal defeat yesterday
when it rejected a GOP lawsuit
seeking to block Pennsylvania
from certifying its electoral
votes for Joe Biden.
So now the GOP is attempting yet
another desperate Hail Mary pass
to overturn the results,
this one spearheaded by Texas.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-in the waning days of
his presidency,
Trump has been very
clear about two things --
one, he's hoping for the courts,
or really anyone,
to intervene and steal
the election for him.
And two, despite his
catastrophic, sociopathic
mishandling of the coronavirus
pandemic, he wants credit
for the arrival of a safe,
effective vaccine,
which we all know is insane.
Trump's like those guys who
say, "We're having a baby!"
You didn't do anything.
All right, you did one thing
nine months ago,
and by all accounts,
you didn't do that right either.
I doubt Trump is
an expert on vaccines.
I mean, his favorite activities
are honking horns
and pretending to drive
big trucks.
He has the intellect
and attention span
of a goldfish
with a head injury.
Asking Trump to explain how
a vaccine works would be like
asking a basset hound to find
the hypotenuse of a triangle.
Trump's not Algernon,
he's the other mouse
that got the placebo, and who
nobody wrote a book about
because he just sat
in the corner of the maze
eating cheese and watching
whatever the mouse version
of "Judge Jeanine" is.
"America, it's time to wake up,
because there's one party
that's dead-set
on destroying your nation.
I'm speaking, of course,
of the Democats.
[Bleep] you, Shoe, you should
have told me to take it out.
It's been on all day.
Side-eyeing me over there.
In fact --
In fact, for all his desperation
to claim credit for the vaccine,
it turns out Trump even
botched that, too.
-The Trump administration
reportedly passed
on the opportunity
to lock in a chance
to buy millions
of additional doses
of Pfizer's COVID-19 vaccine
over the summer.
That's according to people
familiar with the matter
who spoke to
the "New York Times."
The Trump administration
brokered a deal
for 100 millions doses
for $1.95 billion months ago.
That's enough to vaccinate only
50 million Americans.
Now the company may not be able
to provide more of its vaccine
to the United States
until next June.
-What? You had the chance
to buy more vaccine,
the one thing every expert
has said could be
the silver bullet that finally
ends the pandemic,
and you just passed on it?
"In my defense, I was
pretty high on bleach
and hydroxychloroquine
during that meeting.
And now experts are saying
we might be
facing vaccine shortages.
I mean, I knew Trump was
a [bleep] businessman,
but I didn't think
he was this bad.
I'm starting to think
if you gave him a time machine,
he'd go back to the year 2000
and buy stock
in apples and Enron.
I mean, what did you spend
that money on instead?
The wall? Space Force?
Discount hair dye
for Rudy Giuliani?
"You can also use it to tar
your driveway. Win-win."
Trump championed the vaccine
as the one thing he was doing
to combat the virus,
and even that he [bleep] up.
It's like if The Flash showed up
to the Justice League
with a pulled hamstring.
"You can't run?
That's like your whole thing!"
"Maybe I can help
with the plans?
I have good ideas too, Batman!"
And yet, during a White House
event yesterday,
Trump still went out of his way
to pat himself on the back
for the development
of the vaccine.
-We're here to discuss a
monumental national achievement.
From the instant the coronavirus
invaded our shores,
we raced into action
to develop a safe
and effective vaccine
at breakneck speed.
It would normally take
five years, six years,
seven years, or even more.
Before Operation Warp Speed,
the typical time frame
for development and approval,
as you know, could be infinity.
-Yes, the old medical cliche --
could be infinity.
I'll never forget when the
doctor told my grandpa
he had between six months
and infinity to live.
I also like when he says,
"as you know."
Like we're all just going to nod
our heads and agree with him.
He'd be the [bleep] Jedi.
"These aren't the droids you're
looking for, as you know."
"Um, yeah, no, yeah,
they're right there.
Step out of the land speeder,
sir."
"Thanks for the help, droids.
Be-be-boo-boop to you!"
[ Laughter ]
He thinks he can just skate
past saying something insane
and we'll all go for it.
It's like if you asked your wife
about her day and she said,
"Oh, paid some bills,
made a smoothie,
the pool boy was here for a few
hours, went to the store,"
and you said, "Wait.
We don't have a pool."
But the best part came
in the middle of that event
when the twin failures
of his presidency --
his disastrous handling
of the pandemic
and his historic loss
to Joe Biden collided at once.
Because right in the middle
of his dumb, self-promoting,
campaign-style vaccine event,
the Supreme Court rejected
a desperate last-ditch effort
by Republicans to stop
Pennsylvania from certifying
its electoral votes
for Joe Biden.
And Fox News,
of all the networks,
had to break in during
live coverage
of the Trump vaccine event
to report the devastating news.
-I want to kick things off --
as I mentioned,
there's a reason we asked you,
in addition to
your general expertise
and leadership, but it was
that the CDC --
-Alright, we're momentarily
interrupting this to pass along
some news that will be
distressing for the President.
The U.S. Supreme Court has just
rejected a Republican challenge
to Joe Biden's election win
in Pennsylvania.
The Supreme Court has taken
a look at the request
on the part of Republicans
to challenge that,
to re-examine that.
It has rejected that.
The win stands.
Joe Biden now clearly
the President-elect
of the United States.
Now back to the summit.
-I mean, it's amazing.
I'm surprised Trump
didn't look like post-failure
Wile E. Coyote
when they cut back to him.
His favorite network interrupted
what was supposed to be
a celebration of his
greatest accomplishment
to report the news that
the court that was supposed
to help him steal the election,
which includes
three of his own appointees,
had rejected his bid to overturn
the results of an election
he lost.
I'm not sure there's
a single moment
that captures this farce
any better.
It's like if halfway through
"Sesame Street,"
Big Bird interrupted a song
about the alphabet,
looked straight into
the camera and said,
"Breaking news, kid,
no one likes you,
and you're never going to learn
how to spell."
Trump put three judges
on the Court,
and he was very explicit
about the fact
that he wanted them to jump in
and steal the election for him,
Bush v. Gore style,
and he still lost.
When those three saw the actual
court filing, it was probably
like meeting someone you matched
with on Tinder in person.
"So that picture you posted,
that was before the explosion?"
The right-wing judges
on the Supreme Court
are Trump superfans.
They're desperate to side
with him.
If he could have given
them a case
with even a little meat on it,
they were ready to
Hamburger Helper it
into a full meal,
but there was nothing there.
They had to admit it.
Although, I have to say,
probably my favorite part
of this latest Trump
legal face-plant is that
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
offered very publicly
to present the oral arguments
if the Court took the case,
in a sad attempt to curry favor
with Trump and his voters.
-Senator, let me applaud you,
'cause you have offered
to step up.
That to me is a slam dunk case
the Supreme Court should take.
You're now willing
to argue that.
-I believe the Supreme Court
should choose to take the case.
I think they should hear
the appeal.
And as you noted,
the legal team reached out
and asked if I would be willing
to present the oral argument
if the Court took the case,
and I told them I'd be happy to.
-Now, I'm betting Ted Cruz
knew the Supreme Court
wasn't going to take the case,
so he had nothing to lose
by posturing and offering
to participate.
Say what you will about
Ted Cruz, the man is crafty.
As a rule, anytime you see
someone succeed
despite reverse charisma,
they crafty.
Although, it's a shame.
I would have loved to have seen
knockoff General Zod in front
of the Supreme Court
arguing that the election
results should be overturned
in favor of a candidate
who attacked his wife
and said his dad killed J.F.K.
The only way it could have been
more pathetic is if Trump was
giving him a swirly
during the hearing.
And then, of course, today after
the Supreme Court rejected
this latest dumb lawsuit,
Trump tried to pretend
he had nothing to do with it,
and that actually
a new lawsuit filed by
the Texas attorney general
was the real lawsuit
that would finally have
all the proof
he's been promising
of massive voter fraud.
-This morning
the President tweeted,
"Well, this was not my case."
-He says the case that
everyone has been waiting for
is the state's case with Texas.
That's because Texas is now
suing other battlegrounds
over their results.
-He wrote, quote,
"We will be intervening
in the Texas case.
This is the big one."
-Oh, so this is the big one?
Not the 50 before it?
This is like when in high school
when I tried to impress a date
by winning her a stuffed animal
at the carnival, and it took me
a bunch of tries, because
those things are rigged.
And then when I asked the guy
running it if I could just
buy the bear, he said,
"Those ain't the rules."
And then I turned around,
only to find that Kelsey
had long bailed on me.
Yeah.
She went and met up
with Tyler Fletcher,
which was always her plan.
Turns out she only agreed
to go with me
because her dad said,
"If I ever see that Fletcher boy
rolling up here
in his BMW again, young lady,
you'll be grounded
until graduation."
So now, I'm there,
standing with no money,
no bear,
no Kelsey!
Point is, Biden won!
Let it go, dude!
Now I got makeup
all over my hands.
I guess it's not a surprise
Trump thinks he can just
keep filing as many
lawsuits as he wants,
since that's what he's done
his whole life.
I mean, even before he became
president, he was involved
in 3,500 lawsuits, so 50 is just
a drop in the bucket for him.
It's like asking Tommy Chong
to take one hit off a bong,
and then asking him,
"Do you feel anything yet?"
Incidentally, the lawsuit
Trump is mentioning was brought
by Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton,
a guy who was already
under criminal indictment
for securities fraud
when seven of his aides
called on law enforcement
to investigate him
for bribery and abuse
of office in October.
I guess he's angling for one of
those pardons Trump's doling out
to friends and accomplices
the way your boss hands out
$5 Starbucks gift cards
at the office holiday party.
"Merry Christmas, enjoy
half a frappuccino on me.
Half frap!"
Paxton wants the legislatures
of four states
that went for Biden
to just override the will
of their own citizens
and give their electoral votes
to Trump,
as he explained on
"Fox and Friends" this morning.
-Ken, why is Texas getting
involved in this?
-Well, these elections
in other states
where state law was
not followed as required
by the Constitution
affects my voters.
Our argument is that
because these states,
like Pennsylvania and Wisconsin,
did not follow
their own state law,
and that these orders
were by other elected officials
to change the law
or by other judges,
that is unconstitutional.
Therefore, that election...
-Right.
-...we can't go back and fix it,
but we can say,
"Okay, let's transfer this
to the legislature,
which used to do this
in other states,
and let them decide the outcome
of the election."
-First of all, I always
assumed the unspoken part
of "Don't mess with Texas"
is that Texas would, in turn,
not mess with the rest of us.
Second, I'm not sure
we should take advice
about what the law says
from a guy who's already
under criminal indictment,
and whose own aides
say he should be investigated
for abuse of office.
And not just one or two aides,
seven of his aides
came out publicly
and said Paxton broke the law.
It's like an episode
of "Law & Order"
where Lennie Briscoe
knocks on a suspect's door,
and all the neighbors
pour into the hallway and yell,
"Yeah, that guy did it!"
Third, the most horrifying thing
about this whole charade
is the idea
that the GOP doesn't just
want to invalidate
the votes of millions
of Americans,
they want state legislatures
to override them.
That's why Trump has been
cold-calling officials
in Georgia, Michigan,
and Pennsylvania.
He's been asking them to
overturn the results
in their states.
There's nothing you can say
about this
other than the fact that it's
authoritarian behavior.
They're actively trying to light
our democracy on fire.
We need to state that plainly.
The Republican Party and the
modern conservative movement
are opposed to democracy
and want to destroy it.
Just because Trump is
scream-tweeting at late night
reruns of Sean Hannity
instead of rolling down
Pennsylvania Avenue on a tank
in a bunch of designer scarves
doesn't mean this isn't a coup.
It's just a bad one, because
the people attempting it
are traffic court lawyers
hired off Craigslist
who got their law degrees
from DeVry,
or as we here
at "Late Night" call them,
the Kooky Cuckoo Coup Crew.
Which, very exciting news,
is going to be a new show
on Peacock starring
Kaley Cuoco, Ice-T, and Coco.
That's what we get paid
the big bucks for.
The simple, horrifying fact
is that it's now going to become
canon in the right-wing
cinematic universe
that Trump actually won
this election,
and Biden is an
illegitimate president.
That's why only 26 Congressional
Republicans are willing to say
on the record that Biden is
the President-elect.
It's why Republican leaders
shot down a simple resolution
yesterday saying as much.
It's why Republican wingnuts,
like Newt Gingrich,
insist that any victory
by their Democratic opponents
is illegitimate
and must be the result of fraud.
-The objective fact is,
I believe Trump probably
did actually carry Georgia.
I believe that the election
process is a mess.
I really wish the governor
would call a special session
to clean it up.
And the Republicans simply
have to turn out
more votes than
Stacey Abrams can steal.
-Fox, I know you're scared
because you're losing viewers
to Newsmax, but please,
stop putting this racist
nut-sack on TV.
In a medical textbooks,
Newt Gingrich Disease
is what happens when you try
an epic skateboard trick
and land nards-first
on the handrail.
You think Stacey Abrams is
stealing votes?
Trump's the one cold-calling
states trying to get them
to overturn their results
like a telemarketer
trying to get seniors
to fork over their
Social Security numbers
for a free cruise.
At this point, when Trump calls
a state lawmaker's iPhone,
the number shows up
as "scam likely."
Anyone who thinks this
will all just go away
after Biden is sworn in
should think again.
The modern Republican Party
is an unhinged
authoritarian movement bent on
toppling our democracy
in the service
of powerful interests
and their wealthy patrons.
Trump didn't create that,
he just revealed it
and supercharged it, and
it will definitely outlast him,
which is why we need serious,
far-reaching reforms
to shore up
our institutions.
Otherwise, this assault on
our democracy could go on
for months or years or,
as experts say...
-Could be infinity.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
Wear a mask. We love you.